زلزال تركيا وسوريا لم يكن مدمرا للبشر
والبناء فقط بل قد تسبب بتدمير شعبيه
اردوغان وحزب العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات فلو اجريت الانتخابات التركيه
قبل عام من الان او قبل الزلزال المدمر
لكانت فرصه فوز اردوغان مجددا بالرئاسه
اكبر لكن الوضع تغير الان وفقا لاستطلاعا
للرايب اجرته وكاله رويترز واخذت شهاده 30
ناجيا من الزلزال في كهرمان مرعش وادي
يامان وغازي عنتاب تشير الى تحول في
الولاء حتى بين من كانوا ذات يوم متعصبين
في تاييدهم لاردوغان الذي يدرك مشاهدينا
بشكل متزايد انه لا يمكن ان يضمن الاصوات
التي كانت مؤيده له سابقا اذ يتحدث
مسؤولون عن تسريع خطط اعاده البناء قبل
الانتخابات المقرره في مايو ايار والتي قد
تكون الاصعب خلال اكثر من عقدين اردوغان
في السلطات تراجع شعبيه اردوغان لا يعني
ارتفاع اسهم المعارضه فبحس فان غالبيه
المستطلعين يرون انه لا تفاؤل بالمعارضه
وانهم ليسوا بافضل حال من اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه وفقا للاستطلاع طبعا كما
ان مسؤولون وسياسيون اتراك يرون في الوقت
نفسه ان الوقت ليس مناسبا لاجراء انتخابات
رئاسيه في تركيا بموعدها لان الناس متضرره
وما زالت تتالم بعد زلزال
[موسيقى]